nobody has had more consecutive
heavyweight championship defenses in UFC
history than the man am i right and he
isn't doing it again putting it on the
line against Daniel Cormier and UFC 226
Saturday at t-mobile Arena in Las Vegas
Nevada ste paimio Church good to see you
sir let's see how's life for you it's
good
can't complain what's your mindset going
into this fight sir ah crap I do my
thing wind come on that's simple yeah
it's funny cuz you know you had that
belt that's to your right in my green
room and I said you're gonna bring that
out and you're like yeah you want to
give the answer that you gave me Jerome
I said I'll get another one on Saturday
s when you said yeah you'll get another
one on Saturday mmm you don't think
Cormier he's got something to say about
that Oh a fighter oh he's gonna bring it
and he does every time but I know it's
not gonna happen when I walk out the
boats they'll grab the whole waist I say
it all the time
how'd you get into this I was actually
helping a friend out but he was just so
I was gonna school before becoming a
firefighter paramedic and yeah this is
an Ohio yeah Cleveland yeah and I was
we're gonna gem just making money like
you know food gas money while I was
going to school I was training people at
a gym and owner of the gym was friends
again named Dan the bull bhavish and
said hey needs help rustling would you
help them I said Yeah right just help
them out and never left the gym so when
did you realize you had a talent for
this sort of thing steep a uh about four
five months then I was started training
that I could inspire Dan told no I don't
laugh guard they gave me someone else's
mouth guard I got hit Mike you know it
ain't that bad does hurt but I was like
you know I could do this and know do the
best I can and and you know I'm being
grateful and blessed that it's gone well
and mm-hmm you know I'm still a
firefighter/paramedic though because
anything can happen
so well how often do you do that
firefighter I worked two three times a
week
two three times a part-timer two
departments though we're in uh
everyone's an awkward village and value
in their give a shut up whoo yeah
Oakwood thanks guys thank you very first
and value thank you also right so hold
on so so if somebody calls the fire
department on a Tuesday say steep a
Miocic might show up too
help whatever it needs help it medic or
why do you do that ah you know my whole
life I've been helped so it's my way of
giving back you know and I just I love
helping people if someone needs help
them I don't if it's three o'clock in
the morning can they have a coffee it is
what it is but I'm there to help and you
know I I work so hard to do it to also
make my mom proud and showed our son
windows in the failure you know he did
with his life mm-hmm
steep paimio Church here in the Rich
Eisen show so what switch do you hit
when you put on the on the gloves and
get into it get in the Octagon yeah
we're gonna fight you can't leave now
but do you think of anything in
particular to get yourself fired up or
no I look at the competition you know no
I look at there's a lot of reasons like
people ask me did you get nervous yeah
you do get nervous but I look at any day
that you know I have my family my
friends you know I'm a coach is like no
matter what happens they're gonna be
there you know like it doesn't go my way
it doesn't go my way but I'll be damned
I'm gonna go out the underdahl I got and
you're gonna be going against Daniel
Cormier UFC heavyweight title I mean he
he's at the end of his career it seems
so bringing it though Rhino he is but do
you feel that he's a little bit perhaps
more there'll be more desperation on the
line than you would normally take on
somebody who's a younger man knowing
that he there aren't many more title
fights maybe left in his I'm the younger
man I know that Oh what about you taking
on a younger man is what I'm saying
you're taking on an older man yeah no
he's he's fought the best world I mean
he's wrestled the best really you know
I'll go on medalist and Olympics and
stuff like that and he's fought the best
in Rawlings beat the best in the world
and he's fun have you eight also and
listen you know there's nothing I do out
there and give it all I got you know and
I'm gonna walk out with my hand raised I
like I I know that truly okay um now
you're from as you said Ohio you're from
Cleveland yes what do you think about
LeBron coming here to Los Angeles good
friend you know where was best Raymond's
family listen he came back said he was
gonna do and you got a title back to
Cleveland you can mad man no I think
we've got some photographs that I will
describe to the radio audience that's
listening in on the simulcast there you
are holding up the belt in Cleveland
against Toronto so there you are holding
up the belt and I guess in quick and
right there yep now was that this that
was the only one of the year that do you
want it yep were you at the parade - I
was I was the first car there you are at
the parade in the first car so you've
met LeBron then yes I might actually I
met totally met I'm like I passing stuff
and good thing but I I got to meet them
when I went to the World Series Game two
was a game three days to forget the Cubs
it was that I was in mlb.com sweet you
know hanging out with them and right
next we were all the Cavs I went there
and LeBron Jerry Smith Kevin Laue there
are awesome guys and so how good of a
fighter you think LeBron could be oh you
great amazing he'd be great fighter yeah
yeah he works hard you'd be fine but you
could take him down of course understood
absolutely understood and Croatia what a
big what a bit you look at you just lit
up I mean so your your family is from
Croatia my father yeah and watch that
game astray I went in wasn't be able to
fight on Sara cuz I was had a heart
attack
oh that's unbelievable I mean I I didn't
you know you know you had a Denmark oi
who's just on fire that guy you know
more tricks a penalty kick with what
four minutes left in the game the
overtime that was I'm really like I'm
like I'm like this not look good and
then you know they block we block and
then oh hey I'm getting emotional I
think about it I'm gonna like goosebumps
such a crazy right and so and so Croatia
moves on play Russia I mean what would
be the equivalent of a penalty kick in
your world right I mean I'm just trying
to figure out last kick but we're just
saying that it let's just say you and
Cormier you you fight like to a limit
yeah and you're all even on points yeah
just catch me I just would it be just
like whoever stands in front of the
other just without any defense just go
and hit somebody I'm just trying to
figure out the equivalent of that in
your world and they just you know knock
them out and get that W and getting belt
back yeah it's sort of like you just
stand there in front just start hitting
people
yeah what's next for you after this
fight steeping having my first child no
kidding that's wise I'm just worried
about my fight now and then how long is
your wife alone right hopefully she's on
the baby this week are you
yes she could be issued back in so she
can't trap try we actually uh I
convinced our doctor to come with us and
he said yeah for sure as long as she's
worth going like be able to go in did
you took the OB with you I was going to
I was going to okay guys he said she's
not going he's staying home with her
it's funny for my second child ro be
asked for Super Bowl tickets and I did
the math it was two and a half weeks
before the due date and I'm like call my
wife and see if if she's fine with it
I'll hook you up yeah and she's like go
oh yeah he called her a ho he called her
up he goes just cross your legs you know
and thank goodness that that was the
Super Bowl where the the tickets might
not have existed in Dallas thank
goodness it all worked out so then your
your wife is potentially in labor like
you could be in in the Octagon you could
be in the ring with with Cormier yeah
what's the plan like it do you want to
know it's like would you want to
audition no she was gonna tell me you
know what you'll wait to get home okay
yeah it was a really good idea she's
like I'm gonna murder you how dare you
take a fight I'm like woah oh yeah it's
just yeah peanut beam mom okay how's
like well I was like babe you know she's
like I understand she's got emotional I
want you there for a first child but she
better say what you're doing for us and
let's see if it doesn't work out as a
workout you know it's God's plan yeah
sure and we fine what's your wife's name
Ryan Ryan Murray okay yeah well Ryan
Murray Miocic best of luck Yeah right in
your time as a paramedic if you ever
delivered a child I've not few times
were close but I that's one thing to I
think I get to deliver so hoping she
doesn't come out I get to deliver
someone hold on a second so let's just
say is it a boy or a girl okay so right
there my life so tell me about I got a
for you
I can I mean I'm unable to discipline
her yes hopefully she's not listening
right now so let's just say you take
care of business against Cormier you
have another one of those belts that's
your right right now you go home and
your wife is not given birth to your
daughter yes yes you would be the one
delivering yes I'll be there and of
course daddy very nice of course but he
said I can if she comes out I can yeah I
was like you told me that like people
who are nurses or medics training like
that too sure they make made my life I
thought oh my god so excited you have no
idea what's about to hit you yeah you
have no idea what's about to I'm excited
you should be you should be okay so
you're heading to Vegas after our chat
yes yeah few more things but yeah okay
so after you have that child what's next
for you after your first child how do we
have another one I don't know yeah you
know I like tasks at hand
I carry on next week okay less Knar a
possibility everyone's a possibility
I'll fight anyone all right
before I let you go you were in Brooklyn
when when Connor put a dot bus what was
where were you when I I think I just
landed cuz really that my phone was
going crazy like what what's the one
talking Ellison for look oh that's
interesting
um yeah my managers actually right there
and he like not right next there buddy
was in the vicinity of having any said
it was people running around like
craziness going on so you were not
actually you know we're not actually I
would no no I was actually getting to my
hotel in New York just for what well you
weren't fighting you weren't on the card
were you know about was just doing
promotional stuff okay you have seen
things like that yeah and I noticed a
tweet I think we should put it up right
here we noticed a tweet that you would
tweet it out sort of a scorecard in a
way right when it was all said and done
you put a name on the Left column middle
column title defenses
Demetrius Johnson was at the top title
defenses 11 yeah ste paimio Church title
defenses 3 Conor McGregor title defense
is 0 and then the
right column Dolly's throne Demetrius
with zero you would zero Conor McGregor
with one he's leading that right there
yeah you just
it's a fireman thing man you just you
just happen to have an excel sheet on
your phone
how did Connor take something like that
I hey good luck to you Steve a yes sir
good luck to you and good luck to
Croatia and I guess so let me see the
the bracket right here Kuro a should
take it on Russia yep and then thought
it could be possibly England Colombia
sweetener Switzerland yeah that's the
other one I mean beaten Russia you know
did you see did you see how Russia da
Russia
it looked clearly fouled Spain box with
a few minutes to go
var says uh yeah cuz I think I just out
of frame Putin was standing over their
shoulder so good good luck to Croatian
good luck to Croatia good to see you yes
come back here any time well and good
luck to you and your wife and your
daughter
yeah I'm daughter to be the the future
young miss Miocic
I look forward to hearing the whole
story I'm excited you got it steep a
Miocic follow him on twitter at that
handle and then of course UFC 226 check
it out in in Las Vegas this Saturday
night we're gonna have Daniel on later
on the week should I you want to give
him a message for later on we could play
it for him I'll be doing good let's see
this week Romo don't coach the witness I
know but all right let's take two here
steep a Miocic leaving Daniel Cormier a
message when he calls in on Thursday
hey Daniel steep a whole be doing well
I did not say that they're not saying
I'm gonna put a dolly through your
window yeah exactly
I'm gonna pick up the whole bus Steve
Amy Oh chichi Ron the Richard Pryor in
are the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience